hey Luke here at the outdoor Boise
YouTube channel today I'm doing the
1-hour axe restoration challenge I
better stop talking and get working I
got a lot to do well if I'm gonna do an
axe restoration video in one hour I
better choose carefully I've got a lot
of axes to choose from there's gonna be
some really awesome axe restoration
videos coming up here I've got this
awesome double-bedded axe that I am
chomping at the bit to do I got this
there's other beautiful
bearded axe here there's just a lot of
axes to choose from but I think I better
keep it simple I think I don't want to
restore this one this this awesome
little hatchet by craftsmen its handle
is pretty beat-up it's got some damage
but I think we can salvage it alright
let me show you this little hatchet here
it's in pretty good shape the head's on
pretty tight it's got these two nails or
wedges or something in the top of it and
it's seems to be in pretty good shape it
says craftsmen in the side of the head
and it's just a great little axe and
before we get started I need to clean
off my workbench all right let me let me
show you what we got here we've got this
wooden handled it's pretty cracked but
still in really good shape it's got a
little bit of damage right here
and you can see where it's not quite
seated properly it looks like somebody
took a handle that was made for another
acts like a replacement handle and
jammed it onto this then we've got the
nails in there got some damage from
somebody beating on it and you can see
the edge is a little uneven now first
things first let's uh let's get this off
the handle
trying these nails out is not working
whoa
there you go not one of them number two
[Music]
all right we're gonna get all the rust
off with this naval jelly right here all
right got the naval jelly sitting on the
ax head we're gonna let that sit while I
go work on the handle give it a good 30
40 minutes it should be spotless those
wedges really damaged the wood see it
split pretty bad all the way down to
here gonna have to cut that off and then
shave this down it also helped us get
rid of this damage right here
[Music]
[Laughter]
well guys this is coming along really
good we're 15 minutes into this build
and things are moving along very nicely
this bastard grasp is doing a great job
trimming away this material it's really
aggressive and it's nice and wide so it
helps me get nice even edges hopefully
this will save me a lot of time I've
spent about eight minutes reshaping this
handle but I need to see if the axe
heads gonna fit well on this and whether
I have frankly enough wood left to
really do this so we'll go see how the
axe is doing and hopefully the naval
jelly has done its job by now that's
coming along good let's give it a new
coat well that naval jellies still doing
its job so I'm gonna make the wedge
while I'm waiting all right there we go
got a little wedge all right 15 minutes
worth of work on the naval jelly I think
we're gonna have to call that good what
do you think is that looking pretty good
[Music]
well get the head fit on now I need to
sand the handle and get an edge on this
axe but unfortunately I've garbled up
about 40 minutes of my time so I need to
hurry up
well there we go that gobbled up 12
minutes so I'm at 52 minutes into the
project I really got a hurry now looks
great I only had time to sand it with
150 grit but let's get this thing old up
see what it looks like this is
frustrating I've got the fit so tight on
there that it's closed up though the
slit I made with the saw and I can't get
the wedge in it's just too tight so I've
got to fix my wedge really quick and
this is gonna cost me time I don't have
[Music]
oh man my wedge broke on me it is just
on they're so tight I've got this fit as
bad as snug as any axe I've ever mounted
and it just doesn't want to let that
wedge in there I think I'd have to use a
metal wedge
it's just crazy tight but we're gonna
call this good because it is not coming
off
I straightened out the edge and to do
that you grind down the edge and then
Yuri bevel it that took way more time
that was a good 15 minutes and so I am
over time there we go guys it's 601 p.m.
I started this at 4:45 so one hour 17
minutes I didn't make the challenge but
I came darn close I think if I hadn't
have tried to redo the bevel from
scratch and you know straighten it that
out I think I would have made it or come
a lot closer that grinding took a lot
more because as the edge was gwampa sand
I wanted to to make that straight again
there's a couple corners I cut I really
need like a cross metal a wedge in there
but I need a real thin one because this
is so tight and the ones I have are so
thick it would just crack everything
especially this old wood so I have to
fabricate that so I just skipped it I
would have liked to polish this up a
little bit more and hit it with the
naval jelly a little bit more and sand
the hand a little bit more but other
than that this turned out really well
and for an hour 17 minutes not bad and
you know us other than the grinder I
didn't use any power tools so with
really minimal tools and a $90 grinder
you can you can refurbish and restore an
ax you get through it - all right there
we go guys there's another axe make sure
you leave a comment in the comment
section which axe you want me to do next
we got some really fun ones well thanks
for watching guys you hope you enjoyed
this video if you want to see more tool
restoration videos from the outdoor boys
YouTube channel check the link in the
description for our playlist and don't
forget to click subscribe we put out new
videos every Saturday morning
get out try this at home it's loads of
fun thanks for watching